il était dans les starting blocks pour
s'essayer au handisport 500 collégiens
de saône et loire ont pu tester six
disciplines paralympiques dont
l'athlétisme avec le sprint non voyants
c'est face au recordman du monde de
vitesse timothée adolphe qu'elles ont
relevé le défi
les yeux d'enfants voire rien et en fait
on sait pas dans quelle direction aller
en fait ça fait bizarre j'avais perdu
déjà deux une deux blessés mon camarade
qui l'accompagné et puis c'était bizarre
et j'avais l'impression pour aide au
marché parce que j'avais c'était la peur
c'était merveilleux test est robuste et
c'est quelque chose qu'il fait vivre
soit mais parce que je me dis mais c'est
faux pas des enfants qui ont re
découvert le basket ou le tennis de
table qu'il pratique au quotidien avec
des contraintes dont il ignore tout une
expérience inédite et un moment de
partage privilégié avec une star à
athlètes de renom dont une judokate de
la région sandrine martinez médaillé
d'or arides les jeunes c'est celle à
venir et les sensibiliser ce sont les
adultes de demain
donc si on les sensibilise maintenant
voilà on fera des adultes qui qui seront
acquis seront plus forts et plus
attentifs et aussi voilà sensibiliser
les collectivités pour que l'aménagement
du territoire se fasse plus facilement
pour mettre les a priori au tapis le
département s'est allié à l'association
andiamo spécialistes du monde du
handicap
nous sommes acteurs pour effectivement
agir sur différents enfin différents
événements que ce soit de
l'accompagnement que ce soit la
prestation que ça soit de la
sensibilisation
nous allons également travailler sur le
l'habitat inclusive par exemple enfin
toute une série de l'accueil familial
aussi pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
on essaie vraiment détracteurs surtout
les champs aujourd'hui c'est la
sensibilisation la saône et loire qui
espère obtenir le label terre de jeu
pour participer activement à la
dynamique de paris 2024 organisera une
autre journée de sensibilisation
consacré à l'autisme en novembre
prochain